ارجع صندوق النقد الدولي الى اجل غير مسما
النظر في اتفاق مبدئين لمنحه تونس قرضا
بنحو ملياريه دولار كان قد اعلن عنه منتصف
فاكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي وياتي هذا
بالتزاملي مع ازمه الاقتصاديه ومعيشيه
تعيش وتونس منذ فتره وقبيل انتخابات
تشريعيه مجمعه اعلنت قوه سياسيه عديده
مقاطعتها وحذرت من انها ستعمق الازمه
السياسيه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا نناقشه في
مسارات ثلاثه ما هي الاسباب التي دعت
صندوق النقد الدوليه لتعليق النظري في منح
تونس قرضا اعلن عنه قبل اكثر من شهرين وما
واجهه الربط بين هذه الخطوه والازمه
السياسيه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
وما هي التاثيرات المحتمله لقرار الصندوق
على المشهدين الاقتصادي والسياسي في تونس
في ظل الصعوبات الاقتصاديه للانتخابات في
البلاد وما مصيره برنامج الاصلاح
الاقتصادي الحكومي في ضوء هذا القرار وما
هي خيارات الرئيس والحكومه للتعامل مع
التداويته وما هو تاثيره الذي يتركه على
مسار الانتخابات ونتائجها
[موسيقى]
مع وجود الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد في
واشنطن للمشاركه في القمه الامريكيه
الافريقيه ارجع صندوق النقد الدولي النظر
في قرض كان قد اعلن عنه لتونس منتصف شهر
اكتوبر الماضي رئيس التونسي
القمه مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الى ملاحظات امريكيه اكد فيها ان العلاقه
بين الولايات المتحده وتونس تكون واقوى
عندما يكون هناك التزام المشترك
بالديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان على حد تعبير
الوزير الامريكي
اما الرئاسه التونسيه فقالت في بيان ان
اللقاء تخصص لبيان حقيقه الاوضاع في تونس
وتحضى ما وصفه البيان
بالادعاءات والاراجيح التي تنشرها بعض
الاطراف بغرض الاساءه الى صوره تونس في
الخارج
قرروا صندوق النقد الدوليه تزامن ايضا مع
ازمه اقتصاديه ومعيشيه في تونس كما ياتي
قبيلانتخابات التشريعيه مجمعه قاطعتها قوه
سياسيه تونسيه مؤثره محذرت من تداعياتها
الى عامه المواطنين
بان يمسكوا عن المشاركه في انتخابات يوم
السبت
احنا نعرفه ان الشعب اليوم عازف عن
المشاركه ومعنا حتى شك ولا المواطنين
عندهم شك في النسبه الجد المتدنيا
السبت
تشريعيه يتشاجرها مع رئيس الجمهوريه هذا
المجلس سيكون غرفه تسجيل للاراده الاميريه
في اطار دستور ارسى الحكم الفردي المطلق
لم نعرفه في الماضي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
تونس محسن حسن وزير التجاره الازرق ومحمد
امين الجربي عضو تحالف احرار البعيد
للرئيس قيس سعيد ابدا بك سيد محسن حسن حسن
الحكومه الاداره التونسيه الحكومه
التونسيه وبين
صندوق النقد من جدول الاعمال
المعلن حتى يناير المقبل
شكرا اولا اعتقد ان هذا التاجيل او هذا
السحب لي الاتفاق التونسي مع صندوق النقد
الدولي من من جدول اعمال المجلس تنفيذي
لصندوق النقد الدولي هو سحب وتاجيل بدعم
رفض وبتعم عدم الموافقه هذه هذا التاجيل
او عدم الموافقه المنتظره لهذا الاتفاق
المبدئي بين الحكومه التونسيه وبين صندوق
النقد الدولي يعود الى اسباب عديده اذكر
بعض منها اولا هناك تاخر في اصدار قانون
الماليه لسنه 2023 الحكومه التونسيه
التزمت باصدار قانون الماليه للسنه
القادمه
والتزمت بان يشمل هذا القانون بدايه
اصلاحات اقتصاديه التي تعاهدت بها تونس مع
صندوق النقد الدولي والممتده على ثلاث
سنوات السبب الثاني الذي ادى بصندوق النقد
الدولي الى سحب هذا هذه المساله تتعلق ب
ااا عدم قدره الحكومه التونسيه وعدم نجاح
الحكومه التونسيه الحاليه في التقدم
بالاسلاحات التي تعاهدت بها تونس قبل عرض
هذا الاتفاق على على مجلس اداره صندوق
النقد الدولي وهنا اخس بالذكر القانون عدد
تسعه المتعلق بالمؤسسات العموميه التونسيه
السبب الثالث في اعتقاد الذي ادى بال-
لهذا التاخير يتعلق بعدم تبني لاطراف
الاجتماعيه وعدم موافقه الاطراف
الاجتماعيه لهذا الاتفاق المبرم مع صندوق
النقد الدولي الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
تبرا من موافقته على الاصلاحات المجمع
تنفيذها خلال الثلاثيه القادمه بل اكثر من
ذلك صعد من ختابي قادته
ويعني هناك كتاب تسعيدي ورفض كل لسياسه
الحكومه في هذا في هذا الاتجاه
طبعا صندوق النقد الدولي حتى يوافق على
البرامج الاصلاحيه يشترط تبني الاطراف
الاجتماعيه تبني كامل وغير مشروط لكل
الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه هناك سبب الرابع
ومهم في اعتقاد يتعلق بالمشهد السياسي
المتردي الذي تعيش تونس وهنا اشير الى ان
صندوق النقد الدولي كغير من المانحين
ينظرون بريبه الى انتخابات السبت القادم
وينتظرون ان تكون المشاركه ضعيفه لذلك
هناك تردد في دعم المسار السياسي لتونس
وهناك نظره سلبيه لما يحدث في تونس
السياسيه هناك اسباب ايضا وهامه جدا وهو
الزواجيه الخطاب بين رئيس الجمهوريه وبين
الحكومه التونسيه من جهه الحكومه التونسيه
تنادي بالاصلاحات الاقتصاديه كاسلاح
منظومه الدعم واسلحه المؤسسات العموميه
والوظيفه العموميه وغير في حين ان رئيس
الجمهوريه الذي يفترض ان يدعم
اختيارات حكومته يعني يقوم بتصريحات
اعلاميه مضاده تماما لتوجهات صندوق النقد
الدولي ولمقترحه حكمت هذا الامر يشينوا
هذا الامر همم في غرابه لانه النظام
الحالي الرئيس الجمهوريه الذي كل السلوتات
واعتقد لسنا في نظام برلماني ولسنا في وضع
انه رئيس الجمهوريه يعني ليس له نفس اللون
السياسي للحكومه هذا الازدواجيه في الختان
ذلك لكن لان الحكومه والرئيس شيء واحد طيب
محمد امين
الولايات المتحده التي يوجد فيها الرئيس
سعيد بن القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه
الثانيه هذا المناخ
السياسي في تونس ما تاثيره على قرار صندوق
النقد في رايك
محمد امين
السلام عليكم استاذ زين العابدين وسلامه
على السيد محسن
pdf
pdf ببدا ااه المسار السياسي في حذاء
المسار الاقتصادي في حذاء
اتفاق الخبراء الذي الذي صادق على صادق
عليه الحكومه التونسيه وصندوق النقد
الدولي والتي ورفعت والتي رفعت من النقاش
من المجلس التنفيذي ليست نهايه العالم
والتي سيتم برمجتها ولكن كما قال السيد
محسن في انتظار عرض ميزانيه 2023 على
المصادقه وبذلك سترى صندوق النقد الدولي
هل تهلس تونس تطابق الاصلاحات التي وعدت
بها همم في همم في اتفاق الخبراء ام لا
ولكن كنا نقول ايضا انه السيد محسن انتم
كنتم جزءا من المشكله الذي صار مع صندوق
النقد الدولي لانكم كنتم وزيرا في لم
تحترم تعاهدتها مع صندوق النقد الدولي
واخذت الاموال وصرفت ثم
فقدنا بذلك ثقه صندوق النقد الدولي وصندوق
النقد الدولي في الاخر ليس صندوق زكاه هو
منظمه ماليه عالميه التي تريد ان ت همم
تركز حين تضع اموال لها هل النظام السياسي
مستقر ام لا هل هذه حكومه تحفظ تعهدتها
وذلك ولذلك تم رفعه وليست نهايه العالم
لانهم في قعليه في اتفاق الخبراء اظن
ستعاد برمجه الجلسه بعد عرض الميزانيه في
سنه 2020 طيب محمد سيد محسن حسن ما الذي
يجعلك ان هذا بطعم يجعلك تقول ان هذا
تاجيل او رفع ال- همم
تونس والبحث ملف تونس من جدول الاعمال هو
بحكم الرفض في حين انه يمكن ان يجتمع مره
ثانيه في بالاعمال التالي اا بعد الثالثه
والعشرين من يناير هو نعم نعم
هو اخي العزيز لا بد من الاشاره وانه هناك
مسائل اقتصاديه فنيه بحته تجعل من هذا
الامر يعني خطير وختير جدا وقلت البارحه
وانه هذا التاجيل هو حدث خطير جدا لبوندا
ان تكون له تداعياته هذا الحدث يعني يبين
بوضوح انه المؤسسات المالحه بما في ذلك
صندوق النقد الدولي يعني ليس له ثقه في
التعامل مع الدوله التونسيه عموما وهذا
خطير وختير جدا ثم هذا ال- هذا التاجيل
يؤكد انه الحكومه للاسف الشديد غير قادر
على التصرف بحكمه في هذه الازمه وفي الوضع
الاقتصاد الخطيره الذي تعرفه تونس
ميزانيه جديده وبقانون ماليه جديد في
يناير المقبل الى الصندوق لن يكون ذلك هو
نهايه
لا هناك هناك مشاكل عده نذكركم ان ميزانيه
سنه 2022 التكميليه الحاليه وقع اعداده
على فرضيه انه يقع اتفاق مع صندوق النقد
الدولي قبل نهايه السنه ويقع صرف القسط
الاول اي انه في وزاره الماليه ضمن
همم الايرادات المنتظره وقع احتساب القسط
الاول من قرض صندوق النقد الدولي وما يجر
عنه من قروض في اثار التعاون الثنائي او
متعدد الاطراف اذا هناك فجوه ماليه كبرى
وعزز في ميزانيه الدوله للسنه الحاليه
كبير وكبير جدا سيجر عن التاجيل ثم همم
اريد واذكر يعني وان هذا التاجيل هو عنوان
له رفض هذا الاتفاق بين الخبراء
انه بمجرد اعلان الموافقه او بدء
المفاوضات ارتفع تامين تونس على عند منظمه
فيتش على سبيل المثال من ااا السيسي ااا
سي الى سي سي بلس ايه هذا هذا لا يوجد
الان هذا هذا الان قد يكون في علم المجهول
في في علم المجروره توجه بالسؤال الى محمد
امين الجربي يعني هي المساله ليست بهذه
السهوله ان هو هذا مجرد قرد قرض صندوق
النقد يفتح ابواب اعتماد اخرى امام تونس
ابواب ائتمان اخرى امام تونس
يرفع الثقه في قدره تونس على السداد عند
مقرضين اخرين وهو ليس مجرد قرد وهو قرد
تحتاجه تونس لاداره الحياه اليوميه
للتونسيين وليس فقط
لاستثماره في عقارات او مشابه ذلك
ولكن اذكر اذكرك يا اخ واذكر السيد محسن
ان تونس اكثر من العام لم تعتمد على اي
قرض من صندوق النقد الدولي اينعم هناك
ميزانيه تكتميليه والتي وضعت على على اساس
اتفاق الخبراء والتي اسس عليها تعبئه تلك
الموارد وهذه كما قال السيد الوزير مساء
الفنيه بحث
بامكان اعاده احتساب الميزانيه في ال- ال-
احتساب الميزانيه وكذلك واما الترقيم
السيادي لتونس فقد ارتفع نظرا لاتفاق
الخبراء وثانيا ولن ننسى ان الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل وفقا على مفاوضات
الاجتماعيه بعد مفاوضات الاجتماعيه عصيره
على زياده في خمسه بالمئه في القطاع
العمومي على ثلاث سنوات وهي على الاقل همم
تقول ان الترفه الاجتماعي موافق على الاقل
ان لم يكن صراحه فهو ضمنيا
وهذا ما اكده ايضا اعضاء من صندوق النقد
الدولي
موافق ضمنيا على الاقل على ما طرحه صندوق
النقد وموافقت عليه الحكم
اذا استاذ محمد امين استاذ محمد محسن حسن
ضيفنا يقول انه الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
موافق على هذا الصندو على هذا القرض اييي
ضنيا لانه وافق على زياده
لاعضائه بنسبه 5% على مدار عده سنوات
والله تمنيت من كل قلبي ان يكون الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل قد وافق على هذا
القرد وقد وافق على الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
لدينا لسنوات
لا يمكن ان تقوم بها الحكومه لوحدها لابد
انه برنامج الاصلاحات يقع تبريه من قبل
الفعاليات بما في ذلك هذا العام التونسي
الشغل اليوم الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
يتمثل نهائيا ويرفض موافقته على برنامج
الساحات الاقتصاديه التي قامت به الحكومه
في مجال الاصلاحات التي تختلف نوعا ما على
همم رؤيه الحكومه كان من المفروض لو لدينا
حكما في هذا الوطن لو لدينا حكومه ذات
مترسه كان من المفروض انه يقع الحوار مع
الاتحاد العام التونسي شغل ومع رجال اعمال
ومعن فعاليه السياسيه حتى نخرج ببرنامج
سلاحي لتونس مجتمعه كامله لا يمكن هذه
الاصلاحات بشدتها وبخطورتها وباهميتها
وباهميتها ان يعني تقوم بها الحكومه
بمفردها هذا الخطا الكبير الذي قامت به
حكومه السيد بدن في تونس للاسف الشديد هي
حكومه غير سياسيه حكومه غير قادره على
اداره هذه المرحله لا يمكن فصل السياسي عن
الاقتصادي وهذه كلمه قول الى اخي محمد انا
اتكلم من خلال التجربه
المجالس السياسي والاطار السياسي هو مكمل
للاطار الاقتصادي مجلس اداره ومجلس تنفيذ
صندوق النقد الدولي ياخذ قراره بالاعتماد
اكثر فاكثر على الوضع السياسي والاجتماعي
والمساله التبني الاصلاحات من قبل المجتمع
المدني الخبراء ينظرون فقط الى جوانب
الفنيه الجوانب ذات البعد الفني همم لا
يمكن لي صندوق النقد الدولي همم النظر في
المسائل السياسيه والاجتماعيه ولكن هذا
الامر موقول للمجلس التنفيذي لذلك اعتقد
انه سبب تاخير عرض الملف التونسي على مجلس
التنفيذي لصندوق النقد الدولي هو هذا
الجانب السياسي الاسلاميه التي تعريفه
تونس
ايضا راي
اكد يا سيدي انه حظ
وظ الدوري تكاد تكون منعدمه بسبب غياب
الحوار بسبب غياب الوحده الوطنيه بسبب
غياب التوافق والتبني الجميع بمذهب
الاقتصاد يوقف تونس تونس الان في وضع
عماني خطيره جدا
تقترب كلمه فقدت يا استاذ كلمه فقدت لو
تسمع تونس هذه السنه اقترضت احداث
الملياردينار اكثر من مقترضته حكومه حبيب
السيد وحكومه يوسف الشيخ تونس الان سنه
تسعه همم 2022 همم اقتربت من النظام
المالي والمصري فيه ما يقارب تسعه مليار
دينار وهو ثلاثه اضعاف ما يمكن ان تقدمه
السوق الماليه التونسيه الدوله التونسيه
بتمتصت كل السيوله في السوق الماليه
التونسيه ولم تترك شيئا للقطاع الخاص هناك
ازمه هناك غياب رؤيه هذه الحكومه ليس لها
رؤيا رئيس الدوله المطالبه ان يعد الاوتار
انا اتكلم بحرقه لان تونس لديها من
المقومات لديها من الثوابت ان تكون عمالقه
البحر الابيض المتوسط اقتصاديا علينا ان
نستفيد ويعني هذا الامر لا يمكن ان يتواصل
هذه الغفوه لا يمكن ان تتواصل اقتصاديا
اجتماعيا وسياسيا لابد ان نستفيد والا
سيكون مصيرنا الفشل مصيرنا سيكون الافلاس
وعدم القدره على السداد يا سيد الكريم
السنه القادمه لدينا خدمه دين عمومي ثلاث
مرات هذه اليس كل ذلك محمد امين
يعني شهاده كل ما قاله ضيفنا وهو يتحدث
بحرقه كما ترى اليس كل هذا يدل على ان
المسار خاطئ وان المسار كارثي وانه لا
يمكن المضيف في هذا المسار اكثر من ذلك
السيد
السيد مؤذن حسين اخذ فرصته كامله هو حزمه
في حكومه السياسيه
هل هي مشكله فرص يعني اذا اخذوا فرصتهم
عشر سنوات هل يفترض ان يعطر رئيس قيس سعيد
بمساره بطريقه ادارته 10 سنوات اخرى
عاما يعني هل هذا هو المنطق الذي تتحدث به
استاذه استاذ محمد
انا اريد ان افهم فقط
ارجوك لا تقتني انا لم اقاطع لا اضيفك ولم
اقاطعك اولا نحن الان نعاني من تتبع من
تتبعات ازمه ماليه خانقه بدات من 2019
وتعمقت بازمه الكوفيد 2020 والانا نعاني
الموارد الاوليه في السوق العالميه بعد
حرب اوكرانيا وكل هذه وكل هذه المعطيات لم
تكون في في 2016 في وقت تحكم السيد حبيب
السيد والتي كان السيد الوزير محسن جزء
منها ومع كل هذه المعطيات اظن ان رئيس قيس
سعيد هي جمره تكوي اخذها ونحو ويحاول
الاصلاح
اعتمد على السوق الداخلي في الاقراض ولم
يذهب الى الخارج والانا
والان حين ذهبنا الى صندوق النقد الدولي
ذهبنا بعد اتفاق خبراء ومن حق صندوق النقد
الدولي ان يؤجل الجلسه الى ان تنتهي
الحكومه من عرض الميزانيه
التالي اوكي وبذلك وبذلك سيبرمج الاجتماع
ومن حق صندوق النقد الدولي ان يقبل او
يرفض ولكن الصيد محسن محسن ان صندوق النقد
الدولي لم يرفض ايضا لم يرفض اي قرن همم
اجمع عليه خبرائه قبلا
كلمه اخيره من السيد محسن حسن همم القرض
سياتي لا محاله لانه تمت الموافقه عليه من
قبل
يا اخي العزيز والله اتمنى ذلك من كل قلبي
اتمنى ان تتحصل تونس على كل الوعود وتقوم
بتعبئه الموارد ال- ال-
الخارجيه الضروره ضروريه يعني جدا لتمويل
10 سنوات
23 واللي تمويل القروض لا اتمنى ان ارى
بلدي تونس تسقط في دائره عدم القدره على
السداد هذا طبيعي جدا ولكن يا اخي الكريم
انا اتحدث من منطق اقتصادي تقني بحث الملف
التونسي ضعيف جدا ليس من حيث برنامج
الاصلاحات الحكومه قدمت برنامج جيد
الاصلاحات واعتمدد في ذلك على ما اقرته
حكومات السابقه من اصلاحات وهذا تبيع جدا
وهذا متميز في دل تواصل الدوله لكن ما
يحدث الان على المستوى الاجتماعي من من
وضع اجتماعي سيء ووضع سياسي وما ذكرته من
اسبابه هي التي جعل الصندوق النقد الدولي
ينفر الملف التونسي وقد يكون يعني الرفض
قريبا جدا اتمنى
يحدث من يحكم المهم
ان قال
الباقي شكرا جزيلا دكتور حسن وزير التجاره
الاسبق واشهر ايضا المحمده من الجربي عضو
تحالف احرار المهيب للرئيس السيسي
[موسيقى]